hi John hi John hi John hi John sneaking
my balls cold hi John howdy Johnny boy
hi John I guess good morning John it's
Wednesday January 31st the University of
Georgia's mascot isn't Bulldogs they
covered that out of Athens with Bulldogs
and I covered their Bulldogs with myself
that's a pretty normal thing to do on a
Tuesday evening isn't it in keeping with
the tradition of movie magic
Aang that was actually not filmed today
nor was it filmed yesterday those filmed
on the day of my last video but I'd
already filmed the intro for that day in
Asheville so I had to use that day's
footage for today's intro so I'm not
actually in Athens anymore I'm in
Orlando Florida welcome to Orlando where
everything sucks okay not everything
sucks or else I wouldn't be here right
so the people some of them are very cool
John Green as you are playing the
Nintendo Wii I can only assume that you
have finished your first draft of your
book because there is no way you're
gonna finish your first draft of your
book after you get a Wii very exciting
news that you finished your first draft
of the as-yet-unnamed a third book of
John Green and also very good news that
you have a Wii which leads me to the
punishment someone suggested that you
send me your Wii as punishment
oh yeah but I am not that much of a jerk
so getting down to business I have to
come up with a punishment
and I got a lot of them to choose from
some people are calling you a stand-up
citizen for agreeing to do the
punishment before I told you to do the
punishment but you called me on the
phone and tried to convince me that it
wasn't a punishable offense that you
sent me that email I just wanted to set
the record straight on that one now the
email wasn't really a personal
communication so I can see why maybe a
little bit there's some leeway there so
I'm not going to give you the worst
punishments possible in fact I think
going to give you a choice and I
honestly don't know which one you will
choose but you have to do one of the two
following things grow your facial hair
for a week and then wax your chin or
fill a large bowl with Ben & Jerry's ice
cream and then watch it melt
additionally I agree with the majority
of our commenters that in my pants is
funnier than in your pants when it comes
to everyone poops everyone poops in my
pants is a sad story whereas everyone
poops in your pants is funny story and I
think our viewers will agree with me
when I say that funny stories about poop
aren't is funny is sad stories about
poop and I am waiting in great
anticipation for the picture book
everyone poops in my pants John Green I
will see you tomorrow
another Brotherhood
no special feature is upon us and this
one is slightly disturbing you might
want to cover up the kiddies eyes I am
NOT doing what it looks like I'm doing
to this bulldog
how do you feel about what's just
happened to you that wasn't very
comfortable was